major breaking news this this is this is
absolutely huge
the prosecutor
who resigned recently from the trump
criminal probe
now says
that trump is guilty of numerous
felonies beyond a reasonable doubt this
is not
uh
i'm gonna pat myself on the back story
but it sort of is in the sense that
when we learned that these prosecutors
resigned from the trump probe right
wingers everywhere were saying they
resigned because they realized it was a
witch hunt
and at the time i said there's no
evidence of that and if we want to
speculate it seems more plausible to me
that the prosecutors investigating trump
resigned because they realized there's
not actually any willingness to charge
the guy and they found wrongdoing
that is exactly
what one of the prosecutors now says
this story cannot be cannot be
understated in its importance
former manhattan prosecutor believed
trump was guilty of numerous felonies
one of the prosecutors who had been
leading the manhattan district
attorney's investigation into former
president trump and the trump
organization said in his resignation
letter that he believed trump was quote
guilty of numerous felony violations per
the new york times his financial
statements were false and he has a long
history of fabricating information
relating to his personal finances lying
about his assets to banks the national
media counterparties and many others
including the american people this is
mark pomerantz who wrote this in his
resignation letter
the team that has been investigating
trump harbors no doubt about whether he
committed crimes he did
i and others have advised you that we
have evidence sufficient to establish
trump's guilt beyond a reasonable doubt
and we believe that the prosecution
would prevail if charges were brought
and the matter were tried to an
impartial jury
no case is perfect whatever the risks of
bringing the case may be i am convinced
that a failure to prosecute will pose
much greater risks in terms of public
confidence in the fair administration of
justice
this is one of the biggest stories
around presidential wrongdoing and
criminality in decades in decades and
the right is ignoring it
pomeranz also expressed his concerns
that not proceeding would doom future
efforts at prosecuting trump in related
cases guys i hate to be i i know it
sounds like i'm patting myself on the
back
but
they were just so wrong
and my speculation turned out to be not
just pointing in the right direction
it is exactly what pomeranz is saying
took place this is exactly what he says
is going on
we suspected
there is serious hesitation
from
da's
to be the first to prosecute a former
president
my prediction was if one prosecution
went forward
then a whole bunch of others would
but
who wants to be the first because
admittedly this is politically unstable
ground
and it is historically unstable ground
and it's a big deal to charge a former
president i get that
but my
sense was
that these investigators were resigning
not because there was no evidence and
they were being forced to put together a
case against trump
but my instinct was they're resigning
because they're they're realizing their
work is going to be put in the toilet
and flushed
10 to 15 times as donald trump likes to
say
um
they were finding wrongdoing and these
are extraordinarily strong words
guilt beyond a reasonable doubt that we
would be able to clearly establish in
front of a jury of the commission of
multiple felonies
when did we last hear prosecutors speak
that way about the actions of a sitting
or former sitting president
it is arguably unprecedented and they
realize my boss isn't going to charge
trump he's not going to do it so what
the hell am i doing here doing this work
what we do know
is they are hesitant about charging
trump and that i understand that
but we now know the real reason why they
resigned and it is exactly
exactly
what i suspected was going on
if there is a miscarriage of justice
here
it's that trump has not been charged
i want to hear from you find me on
twitter at deepakman let me know your
thoughts
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag-1
by athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi-mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend
in one daily serving really easy high
quality bio available ingredients can
fill those nutritional gaps in your diet
and they can help with gut health and
digestion and support you in other ways
and they can replace multiple products
and pills that you might be taking it's
just one drink really simple i've been
enjoying the ag-1 drink by athletic
greens tastes good
helps me get everything i'm trying to
get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athletic
athleticgreens.compacman
the link is in the podcast notes